So yes we back with that JJK heat, time to
go over ‘the I actually cant believe it,
12th arc In Gege Akutami’s beast of a series
that is Jujutsu Kaisen.
Ofcourse, If you are new around here and want
to watch more long form explained content
just like this where I cover a plethora of
different stuff from a variety of manga, then
remember to subscribe and leave a like down
below as it really does help out with pushing
my content to a bunch of new amazing people!
Anyways enough of me rambling on lets get
into the one and only Sakurajima Colony from
Jujutsu Kaisens Culling Game.
So remember how right at the end of the last
JJK arc we found the Monster herself, Maki
in Sakurajima Colony.
Well after effortlessly dispatching the toughest
cursed spirits and players.
She runs into Noritoshi Kamo, who has undergone
a clean as hell looking transformation.
Man literally had to switch his look up after
realizing he’s named after the worst sorcerer
in their families history.
Anyways, They both acknowledge the changes
in each other, with Noritoshi confessing that
he's lost his position as the Kamo family
heir and has fallen from grace, while Maki
has become formidable.
Noritoshi asks Maki to meet with Ui Ui once
she leaves the Colony (as remember she can
because of her recent transformation can freely
travel between colonies), but suddenly their
plans are disrupted by the sudden appearance
of a formidable cursed spirit.
As it enters, shooting in through the barrier
it disregards Kogane's request to become a
player, telling it to shut up.
Going into a moment that happened in the days
prior, we find a hurried Noritoshi rushing
through the house searching for people until
he comes face to face with a senile Shino.
BTW anyone notice that dramatic change (well
its not dramatic is been slowly added in)
but, in Gege’s art from the beginning of
the culling game?
Like its gone from this very I guess you could
say, this plain Shounen style to a now scratchy
dark type of art thats truly adding to the
growing horrible feel of this world.
ANYWAYS!
The Senile old dog asks how the Kamo got in,
claiming that ever since the guard was taken
over its become completely useless.
Noritoshi tells the old fart he doesn't have
any time for jokes, but Shino eerily ask’s
him if he’s forgotten who’s actually the
next head of the family...
As he continues spouting more bizarre nonsense,
a worried Noritoshi presses on and enters
the house.
Inside, he is greeted by the body swapping
creep himself, Kenjaku, who’s literally
just chilling out and relaxing as he was waiting
for Noritoshi to arrive.
Kenjaku greets Noritoshi with a smile and
offers to fill him in on his plans.
He explains how he used Jujutsu terrorism,
the sealing of Saturo Gojo and the culling
game to eliminate the uncorrupted members.
He knew that because Gakuganji is considered
trustworthy and has influence with the said
higher ups, Noritoshi would have wanted to
plead with him in an attempt to retract the
notices from the headquarters.
So he took care of everyone who wasn't on
his side, like Gojo, Gakuganji, Masamichi
and others we probably never actually meet.
btw the actual text goes over how this in
a much more confusing way where they explain
that pretty much Kenjaku managed to take over
the conservative faction of the Jujutsu World.
Anyways
Kenjaku’s left impressed, as Noritoshi’s
only a mere student but can already see the
bigger picture and acts how he needs too.
Utterly let down, Noritoshi asks Kenjaku if
he’s already removed the people responsible
for initiating Suguru Geto’s execution,
to which its confirmed along with the person
who named Yuta as Yuji’s executioner.
Chuckling at Noritoshi's efforts to approach
Gakuganji and fix everything, Kenjaku confidently
exclaims that the Kamo clan was the conservatives
seat, but now it utterly belongs to him along
with the title of the 25th family head!
Feeling challenged, Noritoshi sparks up in
preparation to battle, but Kenjaku quickly
waves to dismiss him, like man literally laughs
at him and is like nah bro chill.
Confused, Noritoshi ask’s what the hell
he’s on, but Kenjaku just tells him that
its fine because even if he is alive, simply
nothing is going to change.
PLUSS he dont wanna mess up the new house,
he tells him to instead get lost, allowing
Noritoshi to eventually make his way to where
we found him at the very beginning of this
arc!
Back in Sakurajima, Noritoshi and Maki are
on high alert as they both spot a supposed
cursed spirit chilling above them in the sky.
Looking at it, Maki just has this weird and
uncanny feeling.
INSTANTLY approaching them at lightning speed,
the cursed spirit rampages towards Maki, tearing
up and utterly obliterating everything in
its path.
It connects with a blocking Maki, sending
her crashing back and allowing the disgusting
amalgamation of a cursed spirit to pin her
against a cliff.
Not having even seen this happen, Noritoshi
watches as Maki struggles to break free.
She attempts to hit it, but the cursed spirit's
speed is too much for her to handle as it
dodges out of the way and sends her shooting
into nearby cliff face completely deforming
it.
Despite being at a disadvantage, Maki refuses
to give up sensing something weird.
With determination in her eyes, she quickly
dodges out of the way of the monsters thundering
right hook, however the curse manages to flick
its snakey behind around destroying a few
tree’s in its wake and trapping the sorcerer
up against the cliff.
Emerging from the head of the cursed spirit,
no one other than the mysoginistic goon himself,
Naoya Zenin now re-incarnated as a terrifyingly
strong cursed spirit reveals himself.
Pinned up against the wall, Maki’s just
left left stunned asking if its actually him,
with her older sibling replying that he’s
arrived at the other side!
Of course if any of you are confused on how
the man himself managed to come back, well
it makes perfect sense.
Maki thought she took out her brother with
a weapon that was made up of her sister, or
in other words she thought he was killed with
Jujutsu.
Yet as we know, but she wasn't privy too,
Naoya was actually merked by Maki’s mother
wielding a plane stake knife.
So because he wasn't killed with Jujutsu,
it resulted in him coming back as a special
grade curse spirit.
As explained earlier on in the series, sorcerers
have the possibility to re-incarnate as extremely
powerful cursed spirits after death if not
killed with Jujutsu techniques.
BUT enough of me rambling on about why this
fight makes sense.
Ahhhhhhhh Idk even know why I write these
scripts without reading the next chapter sometimes,
like literally right now we jump on in to
another flashback that takes.
This time between Noritoshi and Gakuganji,
where they talk about Itadori’s recent death...
Sitting there, Gakuganji asks what to keep
in mind while killing a sorcerer, to which
Kamo like I just mentioned responds that they
must be eliminated using Jujutsu.
The story then shifts to Sakurajima Colony,
where Naoya still has Maki pinned up against
the wall, his face continuing to push even
further out of the curses shell.
Quickly, Maki comes to the realization that
because she doesn't have cursed energy she
failed to finish Naoya off in their pervious
fight.
However, Naoya denies it telling Maki that
she simply just doesn't understand, and instead
claims it was her mother who finished him
off.
While Maki’s left shocked, Naoya takes advantage
of the situation and declares that he’s
returned to completely end her!
Luckily for our Queen though, Big Noritoshi
blasts off a shot from his cursed tool allowing
Maki to escape the grasp of the cursed spirit.
Darting away, she thanks him, but also asks
if he only used his intuition to aim.
Nearby in the woods, Noritoshi getting reading
for another shot is easily able to deduce
Naoya’s location through the curses presence.
However, he notes that deducing Maki's location
is a bit more difficult which is obviously
because the only energy coming off her is
the jujutsu emanating from sword she wields.
Finally shooting off his 3 arrows technique,
Noritoshi is able to expertly navigate all
his arrows around trees and other obstacles
on their way towards the cursed Naoya.
Spotting the arrows bursting through the tree’s,
the cursed spirit mocks the arrows and their
pathetic speed.
Taking the monster by surprise though, Maki
grabs ahold of him, then using the momentum
from his massive size, sends him flying directly
into the path of the arrows, which penetrate
deeply into his body.
As Naoya screams in pain, Maki immediately
pulls up and slices him in half with her cursed
tool...
From a distance Noritoshi watches as Maki
falls onto the buildings below her while wondering
to himself if she actually managed to exorcise
Naoya.
To their shock though, our highschooler duo
are left helpless, only able to watch as Naoya’s
cursed spirit explodes, before collapsing
in on itself like some kinda cursed energy
dark hole.
Seeing this happen in the sky above her, Maki
begins to recognize what's actually happening.
As it fully begins forming into a ball of
energy, she screams out to Noritoshi telling
him to shoot at it, as she knows its a cursed
womb thats currently evolving.
To prevent disaster and just looking hella
clean, like im loving the knew drip, Noritoshi
immediately destroys a blood bad then uses
his cursed technique, Piercing Blood, to stop
Naoya from completing his transformation.
The beam of blood pierces directly through
Naoya’s cursed womb causing a flood of blood
to begin pouring out.
Thinking that he exorcized the cursed womb,
Noritoshi watches as the burning ball begins
falling to the ground below.
Yet, as he begins to ponder how insanely fast
it could've been if it survived, its revealed
that Naoya did indeed dodge the attack and
has evolved into a much more terrifying form.
Maki screams for him to dodge, but before
Noritoshi even has time to react, he’s hit
with a devastating blow that sends him rocketing
back through the forest around them.
Turning around and calling Noritoshi utter
trash, we see the grotesque and harrowing
sight of Naoya's full transformation into
a foul, repulsive cursed spirit.
Noticing that he managed to defend himself
from the attack, Naoya states that Noritoshi
is indeed a clan head after all.
As Kamo sits there recovering from the blow,
its explained that if he hadn't of used his
blood to block the previous blow he would
have died.
Getting back to his feet and with a revived
look of determination on his face, he activates
his flowing red scale ability to attack the
quickly approaching curse.
Seeing the curse approaching Noritoshi, Maki
rushes over and manages to jump infront of
him, before diving straight towards the curse
and cutting him in open with her blade.
Watching this happen infront of him, the juiced
up Noritoshi activates his crimson binding
technique, restraining the cursed spirit and
allowing Maki to strike at him once more.
Yet just as her swing is about to land, Naoya
spun at a high velocity to deflect her strike
completely catching Maki by surprise.
Their combined efforts prove to be utterly
ineffective against Naoya, who still retains
his ego from his previous life.
Getting ready to re-engage, Maki states that
he can still use his cursed technique which
explains why he’s been so monstrously fast.
In retaliation, Naoya unleashes his prolific
Projection Sorcery sending out a bunch of
frames in Maki’s direction freezing anything
that he touches which in this regard is literally
the air between the two.
As he instantly touches the set of frames
it creates a devastating explosion that Maki
and Noritoshi barely dodge.
Undeterred, Naoya takes off at a speed faster
than sound, confusing Noritoshi who wonders
if he’s fleeing but Maki corrects him stating
that he’s actually just speeding up.
As Naoya if off boosting around, the duo discuss
what they’re going to do now, to which Maki
says that if he’s going to approach them
at the speed of sound, then they can lye in
wait and deliverer a killing blow.
Sensing the curses direction change towards
them, Maki bravely steps forward to face Naoya
head-on telling her companion to stay back
as Noritoshi activates his technique around
her in an attempt to add some protection.
With the curse spirit destroying every shard
of glass as it builds up speed, its explained
to us that this mysoginistic demon of a curse
brings air in through these inlets on its
back and compresses it along with cursed energy
to then eject it for even more speed.
With his max speed of freaking MACH 3 achieved,
Naoya strikes with such a devastating force
that it leaves Maki almost completely unconscious
and badly injured.
Standing above her now, Naoya mocks Maki,
disgusted with himself to ever think her lost
to her.
Manically standing above his cousin, Naoya
states that this indeed takes him back.
There are things children can never do that
adults easily overcome, after you grow up
you don't even remember the times were you
constantly failed.
Laughing at this stupidity of his though,
Maki mockingly asks him when was he ever an
actual adult to which Naoya evilly tells her
that she should ask her dead sister...
Fuming with anger over how her sister was
disrespected, Maki swiftly stands, and in
perfect coordination with her, Noritoshi unleashes
two more arrows into the malevolent entity.
Darting in behind, Noritoshi then employs
his blood bending technique, slicing into
the curse and landing a devastating blow leaving
it stunned with the amount of blood being
expended by the sorcerer.
Coming to tho he makes the connection that
Noritoshi could possibly be circulating the
blood outside of his body and then bringing
it back in continuously, that way he wont
die of blood loss.
Knowing that only Maki can defeat him, Noritoshi
tells his companion that he’ll hold off
Naoya while she makes a run for it, but Maki
refuses.
Noritoshi argues though that she’s probably
suffered internal damage and just a brief
break wont be enough, yet still Maki denies
it, she tells him that she isn't bluffing
and really does just need 5 minutes to fully
heal her injuries.
Idk how she’s healing herself someone please
let me know down below, but either way Maki
commands Noritoshi to just survive for five
minutes.
Hearing this, he tells her that he wont make
any promises as honestly it doesn't really
matter whether he lives or dies.
Re-igniting the battle, Naoya blasts towards
the duo but Noritoshi uses another technique
to form a blood fence before diving out of
the way as Naoya effortlessly bursts through
it.
Noticing that Maki has vanished he asks where
she is as because of the fact she’s like
Toji he cant sense her.
Noritoshi analyzes the situation and realizes
that although Naoya's curse body is incredibly
fast, it's not very durable.
He also observes that Naoya has a binding
vow that requires him to curl up at high speeds
to avoid tearing, thus increasing his toughness,
but leaves him vulnerable when not moving
at top speed.
Thinking to himself, Noritoshi surmises that
Naoya’s curse is insanely fast but in terms
of durability he’s comparable to Hanami.
He also has to curl up at top speeds to prevent
himself from tearing up which greatly increases
his toughness, but due to that binding vow
itself when not moving at high speeds he’s
extremely vulnerable.
All of a sudden striking faster than the speed
of sound, Noritoshi is completely taken off
Guard and blown back through a bunch of defenseless
tree’s by Naoya’s blow.
Immediately following up, the mysoginistic
demon speeds up and rams straight into the
vulnerable sorcerer causing him to start spewing
out blood.
With Noritoshi falling towards the ground
below, Naoya gives chase and jokes that blowing
blood in his inlet was a dirty move.
However, Noritoshi refuses to give up and
claps his hands together, delivering a powerful
blood beam straight to Naoya's head.
Despite his efforts, Naoya remains unfazed
and declares the battle to be over, causing
Noritoshi to fall into a childhood flashback,
so you know big Kamo’s having his life flash
before his eyes frfr.
He believes that honestly he’s failed, he
was never able to create a safe place for
his broken family.
Coming back to reality, he now see’s the
malevolent figure that is Naoya leaning over
him.
Again Noritoshi is hit by the shell of Naoya’s
curse sending him a few feet back, but the
sorcerer quickly regains his footing.
Knowing that no one in his personal life needs
him anymore Noritoshi attempts to retaliate
with a straight punch while proudly stating
that now its time to completely burn his life
away then one day in the future his comrades
can do the same apon his fallen ashes.
(Honestly Gege chill mane you’re turning
into a bit of poet :o).
Just as Naoya is about to step forth and end
Noritoshi’s life, two new random ass players
screaming Sumo and Katana arrive to join the
fight.
So that random man screaming for a Katana
is actually an older schooler who goes by
the name Daido Hagane.
Like the Sumo dude he’s been summoned into
the current time period, but right in the
middle of the Kagoshima Sakurajima colony.
He searched far and wide, night and day looking
for a beloved Katana, until one day while
searching through an abandoned childs room
he finds a Kimetsu No Yaiba First Form Water
Surface Slash Sword hidden away in a box.
On the other hand and also on November the
second, the other culling game player Miyo
Rokujushi who was just summoned, walked around
and challenged everyone he came across for
Sumo.
He challenged every man, woman, and even a
damn dog, but no one accepted his challenge.
In the end as he walked around broken hearted,
he heard the phrase Nokotta and immediately
smashed in the granny’s door to see game
of Sumo taking place on the television.
Finally happy with finding that good stuff,
he asked for a location and was told that
the fight was happening in Ryogoku Tokyo.
Actually love how smooth brain looking this
dude is, Peak Gege meme character.
Anyways, mans like hmmmm Ryogoku in Tokyo
the capital of the east, but he was wrong
with directions, went right and eventually
strolled into the Sakurajima Colony becoming
a culling game player.
With Noritoshi initially taken off guard by
the new people showing up, Naoya takes advantage
of the situation by sending some tentacles
his way, yet our girl quickly shows back up
and cuts off the attacking arm.
Seeing the weapon Maki wields, Daido screams
for her Katana and runs in her directions
continuing to scream and cry for her sword.
Knowing that the battle’s come to a bit
of a stalemate, Maki threw her Katana towards
the old man in hope that an external piece
to this fight would alter its outcome.
INSTANTLY as the old geezers fingers touch
the hilt of Maki’s Katana and grab ahold,
all four players, felt an overwhelming presence
of power emanate from him.
It was not cursed energy but an overpowering
presence of sheer lethality, like a brutal
master of death standing before them.
Its said that this Daido is the reincarnation
of a nameless unmatched swordsman who fights
only with his swordsmanship and not with cursed
energy.
Slicing at the curse, Naoya is just barely
able to dodge out of the way.
Randomly though the ancient Samurai gets annoyed
at the Katana not actually listening to him
and begins yelling at it asking if it was
trying to shame him.
Like Maki, Daido also has no cursed energy
and cannot see the curses, so because of that
he asks if there's some kinda Ayakashi infront
of him.
Confused as Maki assumed he could see it,
she asks if he cant, to which he explains
that if you can see everything else besides
the cursed spirit, then isn’t that technically
the same as seeing it.
Once finishing his sentence he brings the
blade down connecting directly with Naoya
slashing him in half and taking him completely
by surprise.
Blown away with what she just witnessed, Maki
trys to understand how she couldn’t land
any lethal attacks on Naoya but Daido easily
could under the same conditions.
She ponders what it is that she isn't seeing
and what if there’s still some difference
between her and Toji.
In the end, Maki senses a simple domain appear
behind her.
Turning around she’s challenged by Miyo
with a Sumo bout.
Maki decides to enter his simple domain and
notes that it only functions when he wants
to do Sumo.
Its an extremely simple barrier focused on
only one thing.
So you know how he was rolling around previous
to this asking people for Sumo matches, well
its because during his Pure Sumo bout, both
the challenger and opponent must agree to
a match to complete his domain.
Due to this Miyo asks Maki for a bout or if
she's like everyone else and is going to refuse
to do Sumo.
To Noritoshi’s annoyance though Maki nonchalantly
ends up agreeing to take part in the bout.
With a massive open grin appearing on his
face, Miyo finally achieves bliss and his
Domain begins surrounding them both.
Confused as to why, Noritoshi asks what she
was thinking but Maki actually responds that
she was infact overthinking and just needed
to blow off some steam.
With the Domain fully covering the duo now,
Maki enters the ring and as she gets into
her pose begins to wonder what the hell is
it she isn't seeing?
Thinking more she starts to ponder the true
question that everyone has been thinking since
the introduction of Toji.
What is she...
Sensing he approaching attack, Miyo easily
manages to dart behind Maki before she can
grab him and as she turns to counter, instantly
ducks under her left grab.
Quickly springing back up, he manages to lock
his arm perfectly around hers, then uses Maki’s
previous momentum to throw her over to the
edge of the ring winning the first bout.
Standing above her victorious, Miyo asks Maki
if she’s got another round in her as the
moment he laid eyes on her, he knew that she
was much more powerful.
Doing like the BALLSIEST crouch ever infront
of our queen he asks what's up and to tell
him what's wrong, why cant she focus.
Its explained that Maki never relied on anybody
else to become stronger.
Despite having teachers at Jujutsu High, she
has always believed in doing everything on
her own and being self-reliant and thats why
she just doesn't know what to say here.
Our smooth brain Miyo though sensed that she
was still thinking about what Daido had said
earlier, given her silence all this while.
Cutting off her chain of thoughts, he asks
her to stand up and have another sumo match
as thats the only way he knows how to explain
things.
As they continue a number of countless matches,
Miyo begins explaining to her throughout the
constant bouts that she has become entangled
in it all and because of that, limited her
own progression too much.
She needs to instead let herself loose and
experience what it’s like to finally be
free while fighting her opponents.
Then everything before her eye’s, like the
idea of victory of the possibility of defeat
will become meaningless, or in other words
exactly what the Samurai was talking about.
Freedom
Thanks to the wise words of the ancient Sumo
Goat Miyo and multitude of sumo matches, Maki
finally knows what to do next all she has
to do is experience it for herself...
With the two beginning another bout of Sumo,
it skips forth and soon comes to an end as
she finishes her match with Miyo.
Stepping out now, Maki leaves all of the others
shocked as we see our queen smiling for the
first time in over a decade, finally ready
to be free...
Having exited the domain, Daido reacts to
how much Maki’s grown within a relatively
short amount of time and wonders what in the
world Miyo taught her.
Its explained that the exchanges Maki had
with Miyo hadn’t even taken 1 minute.
Kinda like in dragon ball z with the hyperbolic
time chamber, time moves slower in Miyo’s
domain and the time it takes for a 1000 sumo
bouts is less than 1 minute.
Fed up with all of it though, Naoya boosts
off into the sky like last time and begins
raising his speed.
Looking over to the randoms, Noritoshi notices
them co-operating and asks who they are, but
to his surprise they explains that it doesn't
matter who they are, others can think what
they want.
All they care about is the need to hold a
Katana and cut what needs to be cut or the
want to get back in the ring to wrestle with
Maki some more.
Back in the battle as Naoya boosts around
destroying the city, he becomes annoyed at
the fact he should be overwhelming her with
speed, yet for some reason he cant even touch
her.
Sprinting across a roof, Maki see’s Naoya
shoot up and boost off infront of her, completely
shattering all of the glass from all the nearby
buildings as he reaches near top speed.
Somehow making it over and infront of Naoya’s
trajectory, Maki drops down and begins to
feel everything around her.
In the past she couldn't see without glasses,
but once she gained this body thanks to Mai,
she became content as she was finally like
everyone else...
But TOJI, he wouldn't reach that height, he
would've pushed forwards without hesitation
and even been able to deflect Naoya’s top
speed attacks with ease.
Seeing what no one else see’s, Maki states
that its not enough to be like everyone else,
THERE ARE THINGS THAT ONLY THE CHOSEN ONES
LIKE TOJI AND HERSELF CAN SEE...
BOOM, INSTANTLY as Naoya tears through the
building directly infront of Maki, trying
to hit her with his top speed once more, Maki
quickly pulls herself into a ball and manages
to dodge Naoya’s top speed attack in mid
air without anything to actually move off.
Which is insane, a lot of the fights in this
series play off how you can catch a person
off guard in the sky as they’re unable to
dodge.
So it just goes to show Maki is literally
smoking on that NAOYA PACK RN FR
Maki knows now that the air around them may
seem empty, but there are minute differences
in the temperature and air density, all maki
needs to do is use them to her advantage.
As Naoya attempts to boost at her once again,
Maki easily dodges and punches the curse down
towards the ground below.
Maki’s also got that mega juiced up brain
as somehow she knew that Miyo was directly
below her allowing him to land a direct headbutt
to the side of the curses exoskeleton.
Not done, Daido also reveals himself and slices
at the curse, almost completely cutting through
and killing him.
Coming in aswell and seemingly landing the
finishing blow, Maki kicks the back of Naoya’s
curse sending his top half tumbling across
the street infront of her.
SCREAMING IN DENAIL OVER HIS POSSIBLE DEFEAT,
NAOYA TEARS HIS HANDS THROUGH THE SHELL OF
HIS CURSEWOMB FULLY REVEALING HIS HUMAN SHELL
WHILE SAYING THAT THE ONE WHO DESERVES TO
STAND WITH THEM IS HIMSELF.
Before activating his DOMAIN EXPANSION
With his domain expansion; time cell moon
palace active, we see a massive malevolent
eye at the center staring directly at everyone
within its site.
Instantly Naoya activates his ability on both
Miyo and Daido causing frames to erupt from
their bodies taking the ancient ones by surprise.
However even more to their surprise it disappears
allowing them to begin their attack.
Though as soon as they move, both of them
drop to the ground absolutely overpowered
by Naoya’s sure hit technique.
For anyone as confused as these old boys are,
its actually because of the fact that anyone
Naoya touches has to move like him or they
freeze for 1 second.
What makes it all the more brutal though is
how his domain amplifies his innate technique
making it even more precise.
Not only this, he can even manipulate every
cell of his opponent, and when his opponent
moves, every cell will be out of alignment.
That’s why Miyo and Daido were severely
injured just by taking one step...
With Miyo collapsing to the ground, he states
that its indeed a good domain, however Naoya
made his domain expansion only for Maki, but
as he tries to sense where she died he cant
find her.
Slightly confused because this is his space,
Naoya knows she lacks cursed energy like Toji,
but thought his domain would be able to locate
her.
Suddenly Daido purposefully moves his right
arm in an attempt to slice Naoya only to instantly
have it decapitated by an annoyed curse...
You see though in typical bottom G behaviour
Naoya thought it was pointless, however Daido
is constructed of the same material as our
girl and was able to sense her location chucking
the Katana in Maki’s direction.
From within his own shadows, Maki suddenly
appears and grabs her blade before plunging
it straight through her traitorous cousins
back.
As we know, Maki and Toji have no cursed energy,
so they can easily enter or exit the barrier
unless the barrier uses a physical object
as its shell or unless there is a specific
condition placed and because Naoya didnt do
that with his Domain he cant trap her inside...
Going into the twins dream world for a moment,
the sisters are able to reconcile together
as they both recognize Maki finally broke
free from her curse...
Correspondingly, its explained that the cursed
sword Mai left behind is the replica of the
cursed tool, “Soul Liberation Blade.”
That said sword and now Maki’s ignores the
hardness of everything and cuts the soul directly,
but to use the full potential requires having
a pair of eyes that can see the soul of inanimate
objects.
Maki has achieved even this, and, in the end
as Naoya screams at her telling her she lost
because she can no longer move inside of his
domain.
Yet as we just covered, this domains guaranteed
hit cannot recognize Maki due to her lack
of cursed energy and because of that an oblivious
Naoya is completely sliced in two, subsequently
causing his domain to explode.
With the battle seemingly coming to an end
and both Daido and Miyo shocked to somehow
still be alive, its said that 12 years after
the death of Toji Zenin, a DEMONIC FIGHTER
of equal strength was finally born...
Honestly its so nice to see Maki having a
smile on her face in each panel <3
such a lovely change fr.
Anyways gotta move forwards otherwise all
the bottom G’s cant take it, they hate it
when I build up amazing female characters.
So with the aftermath of Maki and Naoya’s
fight its shown that she was successful in
exorcising him as Kamo confirmed her win.
Maki claims that it was thanks to the randoms
that had shown up and hearing this Noritoshi
asks about there condition.
Just like Kamo, Daido’s and Miyo’s conditions
are also severe, but what Maki’s most concerned
about, is how Noritoshi just nonchalantly
decided to throw away his life..
Noritoshi though tells her that she should
know his situation, because he’s from one
of the big three families like her he feels
worthless as he failed to become the head.
There's also how he was named by his mother
after the most evil sorcerer in history.
He asks if Maki asked hers, to which she says
she did then merked her, but now after hearing
what the curse Naoya told her she doesn't
know if it was the right decision and honestly
just wished they talked more.
Slipping into the past, we witness a glimpse
of Kamo’s past, where he remembered his
family and how his name actually originated.
More or less the reason as to why she named
him Noritoshi was that it was the first thing
that came to mind, she didnt know exactly
what was good for him but just wished that
he would abandon the Kamo family and safely
return home to her.
This lil dude who’s Kamo’s half brother
(like I had no idea who this was haha I thought
it was a flashback on my initial read through)
but yeah he asks if Noritoshi if a nice guy,
to which his Mumsie says that of course he
is after all he’s my son...
Boom so that there brings us to the end, things
are gonna pick up DRASTICALLY in the next
2 arcs.
So get hyped for that and leave a like try
push this video to 5k likes and leave a comment
down below with what your thoughts are on
Naoya’s re-emergence I know some people
were hyped and others for some reason hated
this dope arc.
If you are new around here then make sure
you hit that subscribe button if you want
to keep up to date with banger content just
like this and check out my Patreon for early
access to newer videos!
but either way I love you all and ill see
you in a bit bye!